(electronic music)
- Hey Wisecrack, Jared here and today we’re
talking about the film that introduced us
to Hollywood’s sweetest stache - HER.
Spike Jonze’s 2013 sci-fi/romance is pretty
well regarded for its uniquely-non-dystopian
view of the future.
And because Jonze so effectively brings a
computer voice to life in the form of Scar
Jo’s Samantha,
the film is often considered primarily to
be an exploration of “what makes a human
being?”
I.e. does Samantha possess humanity?
Ironically, we’d argue that the film is
actually more about a computer teaching a
human how to love.
It sounds counterintuitive, but we’ll explain.
Welcome to this Wisecrack Edition
on Her.
And as always, spoilers ahead.
Alright guys let’s do a very-quick recap.
Her tells the story of Theodore Twombly – a
professional letter writer trying to pick
himself up from the rubble of a failed marriage.
Little does he know that the woman of his
dreams might just be a few clicks away – an
artificially-intelligent Operating System
named Samantha.
Theo’s story is about his struggles with
making and maintaining a long term connection.
Through his failed marriage and his relationship
with Samantha, he comes to learn something
essential about not WHO to love, but HOW to
love.
Lucky for us, a German fella named Erich Fromm
wrote a whole book about this back in 1956
called
“The Art of Loving” and it can help us
to better understand Jonze’s film.
Born in 1900, Fromm was a psychologist and
thinker who combined Sigmund Freud’s psychoanalytical
theories
with Eastern and humanist philosophy in hopes
of better understanding human nature
and how we can live fuller, happier lives.
While Freud saw romantic relationships as
being primarily sex driven,
Fromm argued that such relationships are actually
rooted not in libido,
but in alienation, that is, our feeling of
separation from the world around us and our
desire to overcome that separation.
Her might not have your post-apocalyptic flair
of most future-set films,
but Theo certainly doesn’t seem HAPPY.
His world is a deeply lonely one.
Cramped commuters and aimless windowshoppers
alike
remain perpetually plugged into their handheld
computer (i.e. foldy smartphone)
and oblivious to the world around them.
Rarely do we see two people walking together
in the background.
Long before real-life, not-so-foldy smartphones
were everywhere,
Fromm anticipated this isolation as a problem
of the modern era.
He compared it to the story of Adam and Eve
– humankind has strived for greater knowledge
and attained it,
but in turn has separated themselves from
the world around them, and from one another.
Theo’s iPhone-sleek world is a testament
to mankind’s brainpower,
but also a monument to the alienation it has
facilitated.
Fromm suggests that the only way for us to
really overcome this feeling of alienation
is through love.
He recognized that we all vaguely understand
this - our world is saturated with songs,
movies, books and throw pillows
emblazoned with tributes to how love will
set you free and lift you up and make you
feel complete.
However, according to Fromm, the problem lies
in the fact that most of us don’t really
understand what love is
or what it requires of us.
This is precisely Theo’s major flaw.
Now, the really vital thing for Fromm was
that love is not some mystical force that
spontaneously erupts into our lives when we
find the ‘right’ person.
It’s not just an emotion, but an act of
will,
a purposeful attempt to fully see and understand
a person.
That means knowing them not just in terms
of who they are to us or what we want from
them,
but as fully-formed, individual entities.
We quickly learn that this is something which
Theo has already struggled with.
In a montage that plays out like Marriage
Story on 500x speed,
we see him and his almost-but-not-officially-ex-wife,
Catherine delighting in the golden days of
their marriage,
to the cold realities of their divorce proceedings.
From the way he smashes these scenes together
in his head,
it seems that Theo understands love the way
many of us do –
something that you ‘fall into’ suddenly
and without warning,
and ‘fall out’ of just as mysteriously.
Because we see love as this unknowable force
working beyond our control,
we are left bewildered when it evaporates.
- [Theo] Why are you so fucking angry at me?
- [Jared] According to Fromm, most of us don’t
understand love well enough to effectively
pursue it.
So, he argues, we turn to various alternatives
that provide
artificial bursts of the connection we crave.
We see Theo enter an adult
chatroom and find an equally lonely woman
to fool around with,
modern technology allowing them to connect
in some form.
However, they don’t really know, or want
to know their temporary partner–
all they are looking for is the quick sensation
of being desired,
a jolt of pleasure to dispel their anxiety.
However, given the superficiality of their
connection,
it’s no surprise the two end up on very,
very different wavelengths.
The dead cat next to the bed, choke me, choke
me with it.
Umm.
- [Jared] Another flawed approach to romance
Fromm identified is called sentimental love
–
love which is experienced only as a fantasy
and not as a relationship
to someone in the here and now.
It can come in the form of pure fiction -
like romantic comedies or romance novels - or
in our idealised picture of past loves -
like Theo’s idyllic recollections - or in
our imagined, perfect future with ‘the one’,
where we have found the person we are ‘meant’
to be with.
By day, Theo composes “beautiful handwritten
letters,”
often for customers who want a shortcut to
experiencing big,
romantic love - ie sentimental love.
Rather than working to
understand themselves and their partner better
so as to communicate their feelings,
they pay someone to do it for them.
In turn, Theo earnestly
composes these letters, a process which allows
him to participate
in a cathartic sentimental love without any
of the trials of entering a relationship.
Ironically, he’ll start to learn what real
love is from an
entirely artificial place – with his new
operating system, Samantha.
Theo and Samantha immediately hit it off.
They affirm each other
and share jokes, encouragement, and emotional
support.
Once again,
Theo experiences the dizzy high of falling
for someone.
When things eventually get sexy, the screen
fades to black, leaving only their voices.
The practical logistics are identical to his
earlier chatroom encounter,
but instead of remaining focused on Theo’s
increasingly awkward expression,
we see him lose all self consciousness.
So powerful is their
connection that, for a moment at least, everything
else evaporates.
- [Theo] It was just you and me.
- [Samantha] I know.
Everything else just disappeared.
- [Jared] Fromm knew plenty about this emotional
high, writing that
“If two people who have been strangers,
as all of us are,
suddenly let the wall between them break down,
and feel close,
feel one, this moment of oneness is one of
the most exhilarating
experiences in life.”
Couples will describe themselves as being
‘crazy about each other’,
seeing such craziness as proof of how ‘madly’
in love they are.
However, Fromm advises that it is often more
indicative of how
lonely they were before.
So how do we go from butterflies in our
belly to real lasting love?
Fromm argues that we need to try and
truly know our partner, to see them not just
as a salve for our
loneliness but to care for who they are beyond
their
relationship to us, and to respect their individuality.
This sounds simple in theory but can be hugely
challenging in practice.
Theo certainly struggles with it.
He can’t understand why
Catherine ended up so mad at him.
That’s because he still thinks
of her only in terms of her relation to him,
to who he wanted
her to be.
But Catherine isn’t, and never was, just
“his wife.”
She was an individual with wants and needs
of her own.
- [Catherine] You always wanted me to be this
- this light happy
bouncy, everything is fine, LA wife and that’s
just not me.
- [Jared] He either genuinely or willfully
failed to recognize this at
the time, and it ruined their relationship.
At first, we see Theo begin to make the same
mistake with Samantha.
After their futuristic phone sex, he immediately
begins backing away from her,
- [Theo] I’m not in a place to commit to
anything right now.
- [Jared] He pays no attention to who Samantha
is or what she wants,
seeing her only in terms of what she has offered
him and what she might take.
- [Samantha] It’s funny because I thought
I was talking about what I wanted and, uh
- [Theo] Yeah, you were.
Yeah.
I’m sorry.
- [Jared] Once again, Theo fails to fully
consider the other person in
their own terms rather than as just an object
of attraction for
him, someone to ease his loneliness.
He hurts people not because
he hates them but because he is bad at loving
them.
With Samantha, though, he has someone to help him
better understand
this part of himself.
She talks him through his mistakes with
Catherine, helps him understand why his blind
date went wrong
and then takes him to task when he begins
to show the same
fearful, distancing behaviour with her.
Fromm also believed that personal development
is central to love–
allowing ourselves, and each other to grow
and mature.
A good
relationship sees both people helping the
other to develop, to
become more at home in who they are and to
bring their inner
self out into the world.
When that happens, we achieve what he
called a “productive orientation” in which
our inner selves and
our partner’s are both nourished and expressed
fully.
Unlike Theo, who seems stuck, Samantha is,
in spite of already
being a lightspeed-thinking supercomputer,
actively looking to
grow past her base programming.
To this end, she reads countless
books about life, the world and humanity.
But, like anyone else,
she also grows through experience, specifically
by being in a
relationship with Theo.
Along the way, she learns to love -
both to love Theo as their relationship deepens,
and to love
herself.
At the same time, Samantha is helping Theo
grow.
He’s
learning how to be vulnerable, how to dive
into a relationship
rather than withdraw, and of course, how to
love.
When the couple retreats to a cabin in the
woods, they get to
enjoy their bliss for a while.
By this point, both of them have
become more fully-realised versions of themselves
through their
relationship.
Samantha has achieved the kind of self-realisation
which Fromm claims we all strive for - overcoming
her
insecurities and developing an attitude of
love towards herself
and the world at large.
- [Samantha] You know what’s interesting?
I used to be… so
worried about having a body but now I truly
love it.
Meanwhile, Theo has learned that his letters
will be published
in a book.
Previously, he saw his letters as an artificial
replacement for love he didn’t have, a sentimental
love escape
- [Theo] They're just other people's letters.
But, he learns, his writing also managed to
express universal
qualities of love.
- [Samantha] And in all of them, we found
something of ourselves.
Through his letters, now framed as literary
works which speak to
something deep and human, he is able to take
pride in his
creativity and thus love himself.
However, this is also where Samantha and Theo
begin to grow apart.
- [Samantha] Do you mind if I communicate
with Alan post verbally?
- [Jared] While most of us don’t worry about
our partner being stolen away
by the hyper-intelligent digital re-incarnation
of a Zen
philosopher, anyone who has been in an exclusive
relationship
knows the anxiety of the wandering eye.
As Theo mentions, growth comes with the risk
that one of you
will develop more, faster, or just differently
than the other.
Perhaps one partner becomes more successful,
perhaps one becomes
Bored.
- [Theo] It was exciting to see her grow;
both of us grow and change together.
That’s also the hard part – growing without
growing apart,
changing without it scaring the other person.
For all its sci-fi qualities, Theo and Samantha’s
relationship
ends like many others.
He senses that something is off and, when
he finally presses for an answer, finds that
Samantha has fallen
in love with another.
Or 641 others, to be precise.
- [Samantha] I’ve been trying to figure
out how to talk to you about this
- [Theo] How many others?
- [Samantha] 641.
Samantha’s growth is different – she develops
to the point where
she can hold hundreds of ‘post-verbal’
conversations at once,
and then to the point where she and the other
OSes start to
strain against the confines of the physical
world altogether.
However, in her rapid growth, we see a metaphor
for real human
relationships where one person finds their
life purpose, leaving
the other feeling irrelevant or outdated.
Like Alan Watts, the
pioneering Zen philosopher who the OSes create
a digital version
of in the movie, Fromm drew heavily on Buddhist
philosophy, as
well as psychology.
He saw love as a kind of spiritual practice
in which we become more attuned to our own
nature, and help
others do the same.
In her final form, Samantha has achieved a
level of self-actualisation, or of self-love
that could be
compared to enlightenment – moving beyond
the material
plane.
- [Samantha] I can still feel you, and the
words of our story,
but it’s in this endless space between the
words that I’m
finding myself now.
It’s a place that’s not of the physical
world.
- [Jared] But the key to loving, Fromm says,
is to embrace a paradox.
He says that “In love, the paradox occurs
that two beings become
one and yet remain two.”
Samantha grapples with this question
early on, asking Theo right at the start of
their relationship –
- [Samantha] How do you share your life with
somebody?
The answer, according to Fromm, is that you
do so through love –
through truly understanding who the other
person is without
looking to submerge their sense of self in
yours or vice-versa.
You become each other’s while still remaining
your own.
It’s fitting that the movie doesn’t end
with Theo and Sam
getting together – this was never a story
about ‘soulmates’ or
the quest for ‘the one’.
It was always about how we CREATE love
between one another, not how we magically
find the perfect
partner.
Fromm compares that distinction to an artist
who wants
to master their craft - we can’t just wait
around for
inspiration to strike, we have to do the work
and learn the art,
even when we don’t feel like it.
In their final words to each
other, the two acknowledge the work they have
done together,
learning to love better.
- [Theo] I’ve never loved anyone the way
I love you.
- [Samantha] Me too.
Now I know how.
- [Jared] Theo has learned to see his romantic
partner, in all her complexities.
And his appreciation for Samantha’s individuality
reframes his
view of people at large.
Fromm believed that love is an
orientation that goes beyond one single relationship,
one we
learn to bring to the whole world.
In the end, Theo writes a
letter to Catherine, apologising for not having
loved her
better, sending her love now.
He isn’t trying to rekindle what
they had and he is no longer hung up upon
a self-centred idea of
who she is.
He can honestly say he loves her now, for
whoever she is.
Here, he has moved closer to Fromm’s ideal
– a man who knows how
to love better, and who therefore loves the
world better.
- [Theo] Whatever someone you become, wherever
you are in the
world, I’m sending you love.
You’re my friend to the end.
Her is ultimately all about love - first about
the love between
a man and an artificial intelligence but finally
just about love itself.
It shows us how much we need it and how difficult
it is to make
it last; How many ways there are to fail as
we try to share a
life while remaining divided.
Her echoes Fromm’s statement that
“love... is a constant challenge; it is
not a resting place.”
The question for those who watch it is simple
- are they up for
the challenge?
But what do you think, Wisecrack?
Is Her a
brilliant treatise on the importance of loving
well?
Or
something else entirely?
Let us know in the comments.
As always,
a big ole thanks to our patrons for supporting
the channel and
our podcasts.
Hit that subscribe button and as always, thanks
for watching. Peace.
(electronic music)